so he's there and I'm nice and tight so
I can feel this I have my toe heel
alignment I start the rotation to the
ball of my foot back to my heel and I
don't mean I just pushed
[Music]
so when I go here I don't want you to
like this you see that difference I just
want you to end ship your weight onto
the ball of your foot ball heel ball
that's it again right Walter rear ball
rear heel right it's all okay try that
picture the figure eight on the ground
you're on your heel step let's go
so your feet aren't parallel and you
don't have toe heel that's why you are
on your heels
[Music]
you're on your heels
are you going back and forth you want
that figure-eight
now we stop the figure-eight at the
front ball
what's your shrugging when I come around
I'm gonna kind of get up so a lot of
times we go underneath right boom this
one I'm gonna come up boom boom and drop
on the ball back to it you see that so
here's just straight back and then here
is the drop
[Music]
okay fire better
that was going up huh
so fix your feet if you turn your feet
away from each other your way is gonna
go to your heels
are you doing like a hippo
you're on your heels
HIPPA try him
[Music]
pick your feet watch your head angle get
tighter tighter tighter head angle
and you're on your heels trying to get
off that heel
better
yeah
I now have this strike and I want I want
my weight to be on that on that part
when I hit so where I was bumping the
shoulder right that's where my strike
hit so we're going to help you you have
just this frame it would be like I had
sword in the back knuckle to that
ribcage okay so that's what I'm using
boom boom boom right when my weight hit
that's what city I want my way boom
right on that okay try
[Music]
keep going
good
use the bottom hand to
[Music]
keep that weight on the ball better
so you when you when you strike you
breaking structure so your midsection
becomes independent of your knees and
your shoulders better watch your knees
knees are in alignment with the toes so
push them out outward energy on the legs
better better okay not turning my face
I'm just taking that weight equation I'm
not trying to knock it it's just a
timing boom that's when everything
should hit okay I don't want to get on
my heels DC keep it on the front
okay let's try lengthen your spine don't
try to hit it hard just let what you're
doing hit it your weights on your heels
your head keeps pulling you out of
alignment don't cave your chest in don't
turn your hips try to knock them with
that left shoulder don't do a sit back
foot you got a hip rotation again
keep our energy along the back leg
around the outside of the back leg
don't let that knee cave in get that
chest up and out your way on your heels
your way on your heels it's not gonna be
any power just shifting your weight
forward hitting with your weight
don't you hate each other but you can
see wounds there's still the weight
shifting that's happening oh oh
you see how I move
[Music]
so that's where your striped would be
right but we're just testing for
structure so won't bring the elbow ends
form the weapon ground don't set up
right away cuz your mind hasn't settled
Sadoway and then go bring the elbow in
form the WEP and keep going
elbow in just form the weapon don't lean
for his head
don't don't rise for his head you'll hit
him just fine
better and again don't set up right away
settles on Shin booms on chin better you
try it
better lock that elbow in so it aligns
with your mass absorb so absorb with
your foot maneuvers ah you know not with
your weight like that move your body out
back you're not moving your feet back
and in boom better form the weapon back
and in better keep going back and in
better form the weapon though boom
that's better
hit the target form your weapon boom
good
mmm good again that's better one more
form the weapon he'll palm leaves pop
keep your eyes up and out elbow in boom
that's it
so it is he comes in right on the door
kid so we're gonna change our training
Turk I'm so usually right in this case
boot kid takes takes the absorption
right so another training paradigm is I
just boom - focus right on this target
you see that so it's not going to be
exactly comfortable but I will not hit
him full power don't snow donate each
other full power but I can now go faster
so he goes boom I hit and you can see
the same movement so absorb boom so it's
almost like he boomed and he runs into
the strike you see that so on the last
one and it gave the illusion that I
pushing him I wanted him to hit when he
hits that foot I hit that he's now
adding to my force
you're missing your elbows in the way
your elbows hit in her chest their
timings off that's why you have to touch
that target better faster boom faster
better he's got to be a strike better
absorb you're not absorbing now boom
that's that it okay sweet
boom dinner faster hop give me that
elbow in boom give it time to sit up so
you're pushing her to the wall be more
ready so you're not pushed in the wall
strike
you're not striking
you
keep going
good
try it again with her rotate your
shoulder out try it again
good good
now with breathing out right good
two more good good